تنتج المدن الحديثة الكثير من مياه الصرف الصحي
، وكانت روما تفعل ذلك لفترة أطول من
معظمها
، وبقدر ما يبدو أن هذه الحمأة الغامضة تبدو غير سارة ، فإن
هناك ما هو أكثر بكثير مما
تلاقي الأنف ،
هذا هو الخروج من cloaca maxima
المجاري الضخمة في روما القديمة
لعلماء الآثار  تمكنت من تعلم
الكثير عن النظام الغذائي للرومان القدماء من خلال
دراسة بقايا مياه الصرف الصحي منذ
ذلك الحين
، يدرس العلماء المعاصرون الآن مياه الصرف
الصحي للحصول على إنذار مبكر بأمراض مثل
covid19 ، وتستند
البيانات القياسية
حول انتشار covid19 إلى نتائج
الاختبارات السريرية  لكن مياه الصرف الصحي تقدم
صورة أوضح بكثير لمدى
انتشار المرض في الواقع
لا يتم اختبار الجميع ، ولا
تظهر الأعراض على الجميع أو الجميع تقريبًا ،
ومع ذلك يذهبون إلى المرحاض
في الأمعاء أو بالأحرى
يقضي الباحثون أيامهم في التحليل.
كشفت مياه الصرف الصحي الجديدة من جميع أنحاء البلاد أن مثل هذه الأبحاث قد كشفت أن covet 19
كان ينتشر بالفعل هنا في نوف  mber
قبل أشهر من الإبلاغ عن الحالات الأولى
في مجال علم أوبئة
مياه الصرف الصحي ، تظهر مراقبة مياه الصرف الصحي بحثًا عن آثار
المرض كأداة
مهمة للصحة العامة ،
فهي تسمح لنا بالقول مقدمًا أن
الفيروس موجود في هذه الحالة على
وجه التحديد يقول omicron  الباحثة
إليزابيتا سوفراديني
، بالإضافة إلى الإنذار المبكر ،
يسمح لنا بفهم كيفية انتشار الفيروس
وكيفية انتشاره ،
حيث يتم إخفاء الإنذار المبكر في
براز الإنسان الذي يحمل آثارًا
وراثية لفيروس كورونا
قبل 19 يومًا من ظهوره في الاختبارات السريرية
د. جوزيفينا لاروزا  تقود
نظام مراقبة مياه الصرف الصحي الذي سيتم إطلاقه قريبًا على الصعيد الوطني ،
يمكننا اعتبار محطات معالجة مياه الصرف الصحي
مثل العيون في جميع أنحاء المنطقة بأكملها ، وتقول
لنا إنها تخبرنا بما يدور حقًا
بين السكان
، ولكن بالنسبة
للباحثين في هذا الوباء ،
هذا هو  ذهب
بن wiedemann cnn روما